all right great welcome back everybody
so this is the second lecture in our
series on the discrete or fast Fourier
transform so I'm just gonna write up a
little bit of the important stuff that
we learned from the last lecture so we
have the discrete Fourier transform
given by
discrete Fourier transform and the basic
idea here is that I have some data okay
I have data let's say data F 0 F 1 F 2
dot dot all the way to FN minus 1 this
is my data and what I would like to do
is I'd like to break this data down into
a sum of sine waves of different
frequencies and I want to know what is
the amplitude of each of those sine
waves how much energy is in each
frequency so the output that I want are
these f hats F 0 hat F 1 hat
FN minus 1 hat this these hats just tell
me that I'm dealing with frequency
amplitudes or rather amplitudes of sine
waves of a particular frequency and we
achieve this by means of something
called the discrete Fourier transform
matrix okay so we let Omega n equal e to
the 2 pi I over n to the minus 2 PI over
N ok this is our fundamental frequency
kind of our sampling frequency if you
will and then what we're going to do is
compute the discrete Fourier transform
the DFT by multiplication of my data
with this matrix and the matrix is 1 1 1
Omega n dot dot one dot dot dot one dot
dot dot Omega n to the power n minus 1
Omega n to the power n minus 1 and Omega
n to the power n minus 1 squared ok so
this is our F
matrix and our F data so if I have a
vector of data times this matrix that
gives me my vector of F hats this is
kind of the discrete Fourier transform
matrix okay so nothing too complicated
it's a relatively simple thing to make
this matrix and to multiply it by a
vector of data not so bad okay
and last time we found that this method
scales like order N squared
computational complexity computational
complexity good ok
what that means is that if this is a
vector of length n right I have n
samples then it's gonna take N squared
calculations to get my frequency
components and if I double the length of
my data I quadruples my computational
cost so it's not great but it's not
terrible in general right ok so it's not
great but it's not terrible so now I'm
going to introduce something called the
fast Fourier transform I'm gonna go over
here so that was the DFT the DFT
is order N squared but now we're gonna
talk about something called the fast
Fourier transform now you've almost
certainly heard of this before
it's kind of the most famous algorithm
of the last 50 years it's the rock star
of numerical algorithms it's the fast
Fourier transform
okay the fast Fourier transform is
called the F F T not to be confused with
the DFT but interestingly the fast
Fourier method is a method of computing
the discrete Fourier transform so this
is a method of computing the discrete
Fourier transform so the FFT and the DFT
over on the right board compute the
exact same thing right they compute this
vector of frequencies from my data and
they give the exact same answer but the
FFT is much much faster so the FFT is
much faster this is a computational
scientists kind of ideal scenario it's
order n log n computational complexity
as opposed to order N squared okay and
just to reiterate I should write this
down this is one of the most important
algorithms that's ever been developed
okay one of the most important
algorithms ever developed now that's a
pretty strong statement right there's
some pretty important algorithms out
there but this really is one of the most
important ever developed this is
ubiquitous in all of the modern
computations that make our world the
place that it is today okay so I can't I
can't overemphasize how important this
is every time you make a phone call on
your cell phone you're using the FFT
every time you watch your digital
television you're using the FFT every
time you listen to compressed music or
images or video you're using the FFT but
it goes way way beyond just
of the electronics and
telecommunications aspect in addition to
telecommunications kind of telecom and
media there's also this great world of
physics simulations so most of the
interesting physics that we're trying to
solve in the modern era are partial
differential equations so for example I
have a beam and I strike it with a
hammer and it starts to oscillate
well oscillation sounds a lot like
Fourier components okay
maybe another example is that I have my
Boeing 747 wing and I have the fluid
flow going past this the fast Fourier
transform gives me one of the most
efficient methods of solving the partial
differential equations for fluid flow
elastics all kinds of physical systems
really FFT is the thing that is at the
heart of all of these simulations ok so
the fact that we have cutting-edge
compressors and gas turbines and our
power plants that are that are
incredibly efficient the fact that we
have simulations of our nuclear
stockpile instead of actually testing
bombs now all rests on the fast Fourier
transform we would not be able to do it
if it wasn't for this algorithm ok I
want to drive this point home this is
such an important point to make so let's
just get a feeling for the difference
between order N squared and order and
log n doesn't seem like it doesn't seem
like it's maybe as profound as it is
okay so the DFT is order N squared and
the FFT is order n log N
okay so we're gonna do a really simple
example now we're going to think about
let's say I want to take the Fourier
transform of ten seconds of audio data
okay either I have a microphone and I'm
trying to listen to some signal and back
out its Fourier components maybe I'm
trying to compress my favorite mp3 and
all I have is a 10 second clip okay so
the example we're going to do is 10
seconds of audio that's not a lot right
10 seconds of audio doesn't seem like a
big deal 10 seconds of audio well what
is audio data sampled out what's the
sampling rate for audio data I'm sure a
lot of you know this you probably some
audio files okay so the sampling rate is
44 point one kilohertz this is almost
always what audio is sampled at it's
well above what humans can hear I think
human hearing cuts off in the 20
kilohertz range mine's lower as you get
older you lose your high-frequency
hearing
unfortunately rats have pretty high
frequency they can hear up to 40
kilohertz I believe audio is sampled at
forty four point one kilohertz which
means that's 44,100 samples per second
okay so ten seconds of audio is about
400,000 samples
it's about 400,000 that's a lot of
samples okay and that's n this is equal
to n that's our number of samples okay
so what is N squared it's actually a
little bit more it's
like forty four hundred and forty
thousand I mean might as well do it
exactly this is how many samples we have
so what is N squared ok the DFT is order
N squared well if I take four point four
one times ten to the fifth power squared
what do I get to do that right yeah
that's right actually I'm just gonna
check myself so I have four four one
zero zero
that's okay four hundred and forty-one
thousand squared is huge that is a huge
number
excuse me
okay ten seconds is really really bad
let's try one second let's try one
second of audio right that should be
even easier one second of audio is just
44,100 samples let's say that this is
equal to n so order N squared is on the
order of two billion that's billion with
a be floating-point operations to
compute the traditional DFT alright
that's just this number squared yep but
order n log n so the log of 44,000 is
about five or six and so this is
approximately one-quarter million
floating-point computations so what that
says is that to compress or to take the
FFT of one second of audio data we get
an eight thousand times speed-up okay
this is the basic step that's required
every single time you want to compress
an audio signal and transmit it over the
internet or over the satellite network
so when I pick up my phone and call
someone my voice over a small amount
small window of time is being compressed
and sent throughout the network and so
if we were using the traditional DFT it
would be almost 10,000 times slower for
every second that I had to compress
which would just destroy your battery in
addition to making it basically
impossible to compress signals in real
time so the FFT has opened up so many
tremendous opportunities in signal
processing compression data transfer as
well as solving hard physics problems
okay do the example yourself try 10
seconds and you'll see that it's much
worse than before okay it gets it gets
more worse the larger the numbers are or
rather FFT is more faster
for the bigger this signal I'm trying to
transform okay good
that was kind of the introduction I
wanted to give you about the Fourier
transform rather the fast Fourier
transform and so now I think I should
tell you a little bit about how it was
created so this algorithm was invented I
think just about 48 years ago by Cooley
and Tookie so coolly and Tookie in 1965
and this was at I believe Cooley was at
IBM and Tookie was at Princeton I don't
know if they were friends or not or
competitors or what but they were at IBM
and Princeton so this is interesting
very often in these great numerical
algorithms you'll see Princeton and Bell
Labs so it's interesting that here we
have IBM and Princeton kind of a change
of pace so in 1965 Cooley and Tookie
came up with this fast fourier transform
algorithm which changed everything okay
what's truly remarkable and I it's
almost hard to believe but this is
certainly true it was actually
discovered a hundred and sixty years
earlier by Gauss by Carl Friedrich Gauss
so it was actually discovered by Gauss
in 1805 so I think we should let that
sink in for a little bit Cooley and
Tookie changed our worlds they made
satellite communications possible in
1965 but it turns out that Gauss had
discovered the fast Fourier transform in
his notes a hundred and sixty years
earlier 160 years earlier there were no
computers they hadn't any notion of
mechanical electronic computation he did
all of his calculations by hand or in
his head
and apparently Gauss got sick of doing
the very expensive discrete Fourier
transform and decided to cook up an
algorithm that was way faster okay
there's some beautiful number theory
underneath this fast Fourier transform
that's kind of outside of the scope of
this class but Gauss really knew about
that and he thought it was a cool
algorithm sometimes people will tell you
that he thought it was useless but he
certainly did not he really valued that
algorithm but he just didn't have the
electronic infrastructure of the time to
capitalize on it he discovered it
actually to solve the motion of
planetary bodies which was the driving
force for most science and discovery in
that era pretty profound stuff this was
two years before Fourier ever wrote any
of his papers on harmonic analysis so
there wasn't even the notion of a
Fourier transform
when Gauss discovered this fast Fourier
transform method pretty remarkable okay
okay so we have some time left there's a
couple of things that I really want to
do today really there's two things that
I want to do today the first one is I
think I should give you just a flavor of
what the fast Fourier transform is doing
and then I want to give you some
examples about how this can be used on
audio data okay so so just a little bit
of material here I'm really I'm not
going to give you the full story of the
fast Fourier transform it's it's not
really terribly complicated but it's a
little technically involved and it
doesn't really matter to us I think as
Gilbert Strang the great linear algebra
would say any modern machine worth its
salt has an fft algorithm built in
probably my alarm clock has an fft
somewhere in it so really we don't need
to know how to program the FFT we kind
of can take it for granted but I should
tell you just the kind of nugget of
math that allows the FFT to work okay so
that's what I'm going to show you right
now okay fast Fourier transform and of
course I will include all of my lecture
notes in a PDF online so you can work
through this at your own pace the basic
idea is that the discrete Fourier
transform that big matrix multiplication
can be performed much more efficiently
if my number of samples is a power of
two
okay much more efficiently the discrete
Fourier transform may be implemented
much more efficiently if n the number of
data points or the number of samples is
a power of two right so for example I
could have X 0 X 1 X 2 dot dot dot all
the way up to X 1023 this would be 1,024
entries which equals 2 to the power 10
so this is a power of 2 so the basic
idea is that if I have a power of 2 as
the number of samples I can implement
the DFT way more efficiently striking
how much more efficiently okay so how
does this go so define we're gonna say
that this matrix F 1024 is a matrix
taking my data X 2 my Fourier
coefficients X hats okay taking data to
Fourier coefficients and I'm using the
notation here that I found from Gilbert
Strang a great linear algebra textbook
and I think that this is a really nice
way to think about it
incidentally he actually has a beautiful
entire course on linear algebra on the
MIT open course where so this is a great
resource for any you know particular
topic in linear algebra you're
interested in you can go and find kind
of this
brilliant lecture by one of the greatest
linear algebra alive today so we write
that this vector X hat of Fourier
coefficients is equal to this big 1024
matrix times my data this is a 1024 by
1024 matrix which means it has just over
a million entries that's a lot of
entries right okay so the nugget of the
idea here that's a pretty cool idea the
nugget of the idea is that if we have a
2 to the power P number of samples so
I'm on the Left board now so if we have
x hat equals our matrix f 1024 times our
data x then what I can do is break this
down into X hat equals some matrix times
a matrix F 512 f5 1200 and then all of
the even X entries and all of the odd X
entries now this is a little bit of a
weird notation I'm gonna tell you what
this all means in a minute I think this
is right so f 512 is the 512 by 512
discrete Fourier transform matrix it's a
lot smaller than F 1024 and so this
thing half of it is zeros so right off
the bat we've saved a factor of 2 in
multiplications and all I had to do is
take my X vector and pick out all of the
even entries right X 2 X 4 X 6 X 8 and
all of the odd entries X 1 X 3 X 5 X 7
and so on and
stack them multiply them and then
multiply them by this kind of detangling
matrix so I've pulled out the evens I
pulled out the odds and here I have to
reshuffle them back together and weight
them this is the identity matrix and D
is an easy to compute diagonal matrix I
say easy to compute because like this is
like 512 minus 1 easy to compute because
it's mostly diagonals so multiplying by
this is trivial there's almost no
operations involved so multiplying by F
512 is the expensive part of this
calculation okay you can really actually
see this if you write the formula for
the discrete Fourier transform so let's
see if I can find this in my lectures so
if I actually write down the formula for
the DFT right my X hat K equals the sum
from N equals zero to big n minus 1 of X
and e to the minus 2 pi I K and over big
N and so the basic principle here is
pick out all of the even coefficients
here and write that as 1 sum and then
pick out all of the odd coefficients and
write that as another sum and you'll
find that you get to smaller 512 sums in
terms of something squared and if you
reshuffle and reorganize you can find in
fact this is a great exercise if you
really want to know what's going on here
trying to take this expression for n
equals 1024 and show that it's exactly
equal to this expression okay this is a
great exercise and you'll really know
what's happening with the FFT okay we
don't really have time to get into that
right now so right off the bat
going from 1024
five twelve has saved us a factor of two
in the expensive calculations okay this
this part here is the expensive part
multiplying by this matrix and we've
saved a factor of two but the great
thing is that F 512 can be broken up
into two copies of F 256 now right now
we can cut that in half again that's
half as expensive and F 256 can be
broken up into F 128 128 and so now you
can see why we want powers of two
because we can keep doing this 128 64 -
32 - 16 - 8 - 4 - 2 I mean you can go
all the way down the line and every time
you do that you make a factor of 2
savings in the computation okay so
that's how you get the order n log n
speed-up and it gets you know better the
bigger your numbers are okay good let's
see is there a last point I want to make
there is a last point I want to make and
that last point is the following
even if my number of samples is not
equal to 2 to a power so even if and
does not equal 2 to some power the best
strategy is to actually add zeroes at
the end of my vector until it is a power
of 2 so we say just pad with zeros so
now I have my data X and a big bunch of
zeros until this thing has 2 to the P
elements until it does
- to the pee samples and it turns out
that even making your vector bigger as
long as you make it a power of two will
make this much much much more efficient
to solve okay so this is the basic idea
of the fast Fourier transform like this
is just scratching the tip of the
surface but it's a really phenomenal
algorithm useful in so many fields you
can really attribute a lot of the modern
era to this one algorithm which is kind
of special good ok so now what I want to
do now that we have this part of the
lecture I want to dive into a few more
numerical examples
okay so theories greats but we want to
see rubber hit the road ok ok so let's
go to matlab okay last time we ran this
script where we created a signal which
was the sum of sine waves and we took
the FFT and saw that the frequencies we
expected were the dominant frequencies
so let's just run this again to remind
ourselves because it's been a while
perhaps
ok I'm gonna clear everything I'm gonna
create my sum of sine waves and then I'm
gonna take the FFT of my signal I'm
gonna compute the power spectral density
which is my Fourier coefficients
magnitude squared and I'm gonna plot
them and these are the the dominant
power Peaks these are the frequencies
that contain all of the energy or the
power of my original signal which is
good because those are exactly the
frequencies that I was looking for
I created a sine wave with frequency 50
Hertz plus 120 Hertz and lo and behold I
get 50 Hertz and 120 Hertz okay this is
just a review from last time I don't
even think there is a DFT algorithm in
MATLAB I think it only it lets you do
the FFT because you'd be crazy
do anything else like if I type DFT it
says undefined function or variable but
if I say FFT it says please give me more
input arguments and I'll compute the FFT
really quickly okay so we're gonna do
something a little more kind of meaty
today a little more interesting and it's
not it's not really terribly profound
but it's kind of cool we're going to add
some noise to our signal okay y equals x
plus a lot of noise times the size of my
vector so R and N is normally
distributed Gaussian white noise that
means it has mean 0 and unit standard
deviation and if you give Rand n vector
or the size of a vector it'll give you a
bunch of random numbers of the same size
okay so I'm gonna plot my original
signal next to my noisy signal and I
want to plot this in red I believe and
I'm gonna make a legend that says the
first signal is clean and the second
signal is noisy
cool all right so this is great here we
see the blue signal is our actual sum of
two signs frequency and this red is just
a lot a significant amount of noise
added to my signal
now if you just looked at the red curve
you might say to yourself that looks
like it has four or five frequencies and
I bet you wouldn't pull out fifty and a
hundred and twenty just by eye okay um
okay so now instead of taking the
Fourier transform of my clean data X I'm
going to take the transform of my nasty
noisy data Y okay and so now we see this
is the FFT of my noisy data we still see
these beautiful peaks at now it's 49.95
right fifty Hertz and 120 Hertz but
there's the significant noise baseline
that exists now because we added a lot
of noise right we added noise that kind
of has so white noise is known to have
power at all frequencies there which is
what you're seeing here is this kind of
uniform power at all frequencies so this
is really cool that the FFT is giving us
a very clear readout on the frequencies
that are under all of this noise all
this noise great well so now I start
thinking to myself maybe I can use the
pout like maybe I can use this power
spectrum to actually filter my signal
right I know that if I have a big peak
it's probably not just noise and
everything else is a coincidence and I
can throw it away so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to say if my power
spectral density is lower than 50 that's
about the cutoff here I'm going to set
it equal to zero manual I'm just gonna
zero out the noise baseline the noise
floor and then I'm going to inverse
Fourier transform and try to
reconstruct my signal all right so let's
see what I want to do here I really want
this in a sub blocks okay and I'm gonna
have a code that uses the power spectral
density to filter out noise okay indices
equals PSD greater than 50 so PSD was a
big vector I created and here what I'm
doing is if any of those entries are
greater than 50 the that position of the
indices vector will have a 1 in it all
the variables that are lower than 50
will have a 0 so this is going to be a
big vector the same size as PSD with
zeros wherever PSD is less than 50 and
ones where it's greater than 50 this is
really cool this is a logical statement
to fill a vector you can use it to fill
a matrix too and then I'm just going to
say PSD equals PSD dot times indices so
wherever the indicee is one meaning that
I had a large power at that band I'm
gonna keep it I'm gonna multiply it by
one wherever there was very little power
and I think it might be noise I'm gonna
multiply it by a zero index so this
zeroes out all others and removes the
noise floor I'm gonna use jargon so that
you get a feeling for it that's called
the noise floor okay I'm gonna hold on
I'm gonna plot my frequency L versus my
new PS DL in red this is my original and
filtered filtered okay good I think I
killed my computer because it's not
called legend it's called legend good
all right
so we had the data
we added a bunch of noise to it then we
looked at the fft the power spectral
density in particular the magnitude
square of those Fourier coefficients so
my coefficients you know f0 hat f1 hat I
look at the square magnitude of those
things and that's this power spectral
density here now the red curve is my
filtered one where a zero out all of
this kind of blue noisy crap and all I'm
left with are these nice perfect clean
red peaks and the only last step is to
inverse Fourier transform okay so my
Fourier coefficients why I'm going to
multiply them by my indices dot times
indices so I'm gonna zero out small
Fourier coefficients and Y and I'm gonna
say Y filter equals the IFFT the inverse
for fast Fourier transform of Y and this
is the inverse FFT to get filtered time
domain signal ok and now all I have to
do is plot it so I'm gonna go back to my
figure one I'm gonna go to my subplots
and I'm gonna plot time X the true clean
signal in blue and then I'm gonna hold
on and plop the filtered signal in red
and I want an axis just to see what's
happening now I forget that
okay something died
I need a parenthesis okay
all right so after I filtered out that
noise if i zoom in here I see that my
filtered signal matches almost perfectly
to my actual true data so this is really
cool I didn't know anything about the
kind of blue clean signal here all that
I was given was this nasty noisy red
data so from the nasty noisy red data I
computed the FFT and looked at the power
spectrum and I got this blue curve with
these Peaks and all the noise eyes Eero
out all of the small coefficients I
filter and when I inverse Fourier
transform I get this beautiful clean
reconstruction okay so this is fantastic
the fast Fourier transform has an even
another application right it can filter
beautifully let's say I don't have as
much of a signal instead of from x 0 to
1 which is a thousand samples let's say
I only have a quarter of a second and I
run the same thing so now this is just a
quarter second of noisy data and now an
IFFT notice that my 50 Hertz is barely
above the noise baseline and if I just
looked at this signal I might actually
think I need to cut off at 20 because
these look kind of important so let's
cut off our filter at 20
right so we actually keeping a lot of
nasty peaks and our reconstruction
doesn't do very good however if I go
back and I make my signal longer
I should probably close all my figures
my filtering is significantly better
this is not a very compelling example
let's try 50 all right so what I'm
trying to say maybe I'm not doing a
great job of saying it so let me try to
reiterate so if I only have a short
sample maybe 1/4 second of data and it's
really noisy I might kind of get
spurious Peaks in the power spectrum and
it's gonna be harder to filter but the
solution is quite simple all I have to
do is just wait longer and collect more
data ok and my filtering gets better and
better
ok the last thing we can do is we can
actually play the sound so MATLAB is
really cool you can say sound of y1 over
DT let's see if this works
ok I'm gonna make it a little bit longer
maybe 2 or 3 seconds just so that you
can hear it so that's what the noisy 2
frequency sign sounds like let's see
what the clean sound wait sine wave
sounds like
much cleaner I'm not sure if you can
hear it
my MATLAB dies okay so that's the basic
the basic idea of using the FFT to
filter okay so I have maybe five minutes
left and I'm going to give you one last
cool well maybe two cool last examples
of the FFT and this is called the
spectrogram okay so I'm just going to
run this one more time
okay so the spectrogram is this
beautiful kind of technique that you can
use to visualize and analyze audio data
and what it does is really cool in fact
maybe I'll just do it on that lab I
think it's easier so I have this example
called load music there's free
open-source software called mp3 read and
you can find it at math works comm on
the matlab central file exchange and
it's this really cool code that allows
you to pull in mp3s
so unfortunately on the website I can't
share a copyrighted music like this Led
Zeppelin song but I can play it in the
lecture so I have a file called zap mp3
and I'm gonna load it in this takes a
little while because it's kind of a big
file maybe 60 megabytes uncompressed and
I'm gonna play five seconds of this song
this is just me formatting the data and
here I'm going to plot it first of all
so this is what the audio signal looks
like and if i zoom in I mean this is a
lot of data a lot a lot of data let's
just play the sound real quick let's try
it one more time
okay that's the first five seconds of a
really good Led Zeppelin song okay
and there's this great built-in command
in MATLAB its built-in on the student
version at least called spectrogram now
I'm not going to kind of tell you
everything about spectrogram I really
think you should type help spectrogram
and get a nice overview of all of the
bells and whistles that you can apply
but basically what the spectrogram is
going to do is it's going to take your
five second audio clip and it's going to
break it up into a bunch of smaller
windows and do the FFT and those smaller
windows so that you can get a plot of
the frequency content in time
let's see what that looks like so this
is the spectrogram for that that Led
Zeppelin song let me just bring it down
here so that it stays visible when I
play the song again
so the song time is going from left to
right and these are the frequencies
represented at each moment of time so
these are low frequencies and high
frequencies and notice these band
structures what do you think that these
banded structures represent well these
are the chords and the harmonics of
these guitar chords being played one
after the other so you can actually see
time being kept you know these are the
the timings of each of these chord
transitions and plucking of different
strengths okay so that's kind of cool I
think that there's some really great
examples on YouTube so I'm just gonna
see if I can find one YouTube not you
but YouTube's spectrogram beeth oven all
right let's see what Beethoven has this
is pretty phenomenal stuff
notice here that there are tons of
vertical bands that are excited that
have large Fourier coefficients now the
piano player probably doesn't have I
don't know 50 or 60 fingers so these are
really the harmonics that are being
excited by these chords and these
complex resonating sounds so anyway this
is just kind of a nice pictorial
illustration of the FFT you the Fourier
spectrum and next lecture we're going to
be talking about images and image
compression using the FFT which is
really one of my kind of favorite topics
on the subject okay so that's all for
today I'll see you in the next lecture
thank you